thank you alejandro yes we are indeed
with grandmaster faviano caruana one of
the best chess players on the planet
fabi welcome back to st louis tell us a
little bit about your last few months
yeah i've been out of town for a while
so it's pretty much my like my third day
back in st louis and uh in time for this
tournament it's uh it's good to see that
chess is um
it's coming back to over the board and
uh there's more and more events and
um this is an incredibly strong
tournament actually i was i was
surprised to see just how many um
really strong players there are tell us
a little bit about that back when you
were 25 2600 did you have this type of
opportunities of closed events competing
against the best chess players around
your rating
um
no where were those opportunities it was
mostly open events um that i played when
i was around that level even up to 2700
mostly
mostly open tournaments i played a lot
of tournaments in spain
um
i had like some close tournaments there
was this uh i think they still exist
this um series of tournaments that went
every
every month in in hungary called the
first saturday first saturday
tournaments right they were they were
closed events um but not not nearly at
this level they were maybe between
twenty three to twenty five hundred most
players so maybe average rating twenty
four hundred um
this level of tournaments like average
of twenty six
twenty six many players twenty six fifty
even close to twenty seven hundred
uh is is actually incredibly rare you
traditionally you had that
those uh you know open tournaments and
then the super tournament super elite
events yeah which are 27 50 plus let's
say
so this uh this is actually a somewhat
neglected area in chess
players of this level they're
professionals they're very strong but
they uh
someone get overlooked in terms of
opportunities
of being able to play and improve
because these are type events which help
these players
improve their chess we were very happy
to see the classics return to the saint
louis chess club you were mentioning
that there's a lot of talent in these
two fields which player caught your eyes
uh
it's hard to say because a lot of
players i i know pretty well i've played
a lot of them many times like a lot are
quite established like let's say jeffrey
is one of the top players in the united
states he's a very established player
and sam savion was
tied for first in the last u.s
championship and
didn't win on on um in the playoff but
still he's incredibly strong too
um hans neiman is a slightly newer name
i i got a chance to see his games more
recently he's obviously very talented
and i suspect he'll at some point make
that push to 2700 but he's he's not
quite as established established as some
of the other guys but yeah there's a lot
of um well he was 2500 last year yeah
yeah he's moving super fast up up the
ranks
but yeah there's a lot of
a lot of very talented players some
more up up and coming some who are a bit
more established in the scene well since
we have you in the studio we're going to
have to take advantage of that and use
you what game should we go to
oh well the game you have up is actually
pretty pretty interesting i don't know
if that's a live position that is the
live position actually rook f6 was
played after we can go forward a couple
of moves let me bring it up just one
second
i
lost it somehow
not this one
this one is over
why can't i find it i'm pulling out yeah
very interesting one as that one is
interesting as well but i'm
missing the hans neiman game for some
reason from my you can pull it up
christian first absolutely yes
so we do have this position right now on
the board i think queen to e7 was played
by the way
um the it seems like maybe the only way
to defend this position was to spot this
ridiculous tactic with rook to a7 and if
you go knight to b7 now i have this move
knight to f3 ah
a7 is a really weird movie because at
least good luck d6 hanging it's not even
knight b7 but it just leaves d6 hanging
which i guess root and id d3 is such an
important resource
uh because once white black's queen gets
to e3 he has so many checks
um yeah or work f7 queen three suddenly
we're already it seems looking at sort
of yeah maybe even queen six years 26
okay so it's uh
this is probably okay but yeah rook a7
is uh is a really surprising move so
actually rook a7 probably was missed by
both players because we did see hans
very confidently very quickly played
this move rook c f1 probably not
spotting rook a7 if that's the only
defense you can completely understand
why he thought he was com in the
driver's seat the move queen e7 tried to
solidify the entire game it came down
but it's just not enough knight b7 rook
a6 rook f6 on the board and ray down to
two and a half minutes for the remaining
seven moves
that's going to be a very tall order but
objectively this position might just be
completely lost yeah he might try to
maybe because he has to defend d6 once
that falls it's all over and if he plays
oh he took on b4 but now knight d6 let's
take a look 1966 because it also
threatens
well the rook the pawn f7 even some
somewhere queen e5
uh could be in it although you have to
be careful there because then black's
pawns in the end game could get rolling
so if i just simply go rook to d8 now
rook to d8 um
here i think i do take on wait if i
let's point out that if i take on e5
there's also the important
fact that
after the move king g7
this rook's actually under attack uh
after work to d8 yeah this one this one
is
is
not what white wants it
after yeah maybe knight f7 in fact
because i'm in check black should play
knight takes f7 right now i'll take with
the rook
here yeah you probably want to trade
queens otherwise you'll get mated uh so
rook d5 rookie 7 and you pick up b4 like
rook d8 is forced you pick up before you
just have two pawns and rook f7 is
coming
so this might clean it up very
comfortably that is resigns
um but there there's likely also other
other ways to finish it off
so let's see if it goes knight takes d6
how does black defend at this point he
might not right yeah that's the only
thing
maybe rook takes d6 and just say okay
i'm going to give you the exchange and
potentially take on a3 and maybe i'll do
something with those two connected
passers this is probably the right way
but after b takes a3 or d6ba3 queen d4
you um
well your pawns are not moving so
quickly
so let's go
if i go a2 you go row k6 yeah probably
just work k6 yeah this guy i think white
keeps control here very very well
there's still rook d8 and there's some
mess but you know unless black is
promoting that pawn it's going to be
winning for white can't try for some
rook c2 business no probably too slow
right rook c2 maybe uh can i play rook
f7 i don't want to
yeah this is a bit of a disaster right
that's all shiro let me just put this on
the board that here i'm going to follow
it up with rook a8 that's a back rank no
matter if you go to king g8 or queen g7
you're going to lose the game because
actually let's keep going queen to f8 ah
you have queen to g5 yeah here queen g5
gg5 is probably the easiest just don't
take the queen immediately then you
might have
yeah it might have ruined it yeah yes
but this wins the queen and that's
that's it yeah that's game over how much
time does hans have han still has uh six
minutes to figure out what's going on in
the position six minutes and 10 seconds
so he does have the time to think about
things and as we mentioned it's not
necessarily the only way to
increase the advantage i'm also
wondering if you could just take back
the pawn on b4 it's probably not the
cleanest
but it does ask some
so if you take on b4 my guess is that he
just simply wants to go maybe rookie one
some sort of uh tactics like that
okay one of course using the fact that
the rook is overloaded defending the
first rank and
the
rook on f6
you know i start looking at this i think
maybe i'm winning anyway
but
why go into it right it starts to get
messy i mean maybe you can still play
rook a1 queen f6 and knight d6
and then black has to play knight to f3
check because there's queen e5 tactics
yes so knight f3 king h1
and
it's hard to say because white's king is
also potentially a mating that you know
after like rook c2
uh on the other hand maybe
maybe white wins um after rook e8
but yeah it's it gets very tricky this
is how you this is how you're doing you
might because king king g6 and the king
or even king h6 and the king has
no more white can't give any more checks
to the king and black actually wins this
i think
um that's checkmate that's a difficult
to stop checkmate
so so yeah this is how you uh
potentially spoil winning positions you
still have rook to a2 but
uh you're probably going to get
checkmated after yeah
well your king on f2 is maybe safe
here although even the move queen c6
looks or queen
queen c6 yeah or queen g5 it's hard to
say no queen g5 allows queen a6 so
queen c6 seems very potent yeah but we
don't expect any of this i think the
moment you start to see that it gets
messy you just switch to the other
variation remember that hans doesn't
have that much time himself now
currently only at four minutes and 15
seconds he does have to make a decision
um
that will give him the
cleanest way
to win this game
well he's he's quite a good
blitz player uh i think he
sort of specializes in fast time
controls because he's so
i've seen him play so much online chess
so he's probably not too worried about
the
the lack of time here but you never know
i mean even the
the best players can
can panic when when they're low on time
and and blunder i mean especially here
it's easy to blunder
easy to to miss some small tactic and
the game the
entire evaluation reverses itself
i think we're going to stay here for a
little bit as it is the most exciting
game on both players going down to the
wire enhanced keeps burning time
certainly making his fans nervous
is what is there else to think knight
take the six eight takes before seem
like the only choices to me
it feels like that is the critical line
that he's calculating just that
uh
he actually played it he just took back
he didn't play with knight takes d6 we
didn't really see uh the exact problem
with knight takes d6 we thought he was
winning and after pawn takes before ray
and he's a crafty player i've had the
terrible experience of playing ray
robson when he's in time control
and it's just like he finds every
resource to keep himself afloat doesn't
matter that he's down to 30 seconds and
let's see if he finds speaking of
resources alejandro we were mentioning
the move rook to c1 but check this line
out rook to c2
c2 immediately now the big threat
is that if you take on d6 with the
knight i'm actually going to be able to
take on f6 with the queen
very tricky very very very tricky
let's show it on the board we got check
here this is a background check except
for the rook but this knight f3 kicks
out the king and then i'll have a
pleasant choice between rook takes f1 or
rook takes h2 checkmate that is not
going to be good
rook c1 or rook c2 both of them were
worked to c1 and rook to c2 we were
mentioning rook to a1 he played rook to
c2 and he played rousseau
oh man i see rook c2 and i'm starting to
get nervous
so another question is can white if
queen takes d4 then black will switch
the idea in player i think rook to a2
because that's the second idea of rook
c2
um
even if the a1 square is covered black
still has this very dangerous looking
like let's say maybe white still has
rook six to f2
but uh wait do i have uh
now they're gonna be king
but queen to f6 is actually maybe nicer
that's a brilliant move let's just
explain it to the viewers rick takes f6
cannot be played because check check the
other rook will come with checkmate to
g2
and if you take my rook
this comes crashing down knight f3 check
i'll take the queen with check on the
next move as well
and yeah this looks this is not i mean
there's still okay that's right yeah
king h1 night but we're already talking
about black trying to win rather than
white trying to win yes absolutely
especially as always with this terrible
night on b7 this end game looks more
promising for black than for white after
i take on d3
yes so yeah now we could see any result
they're both low on time
and they still have six moves to make so
six moves to make it's not easy gonna
get tense easy for white to lose this
one as well absolutely
so if not rook six f2 what else do we
have on st in store here for white we
saw knight takes d6 loses to queen takes
f6 i think that is pretty clear right
because rook takes d6
rook takes d6 when rook a2 it doesn't
really solve this issue because rook d8
king g7
is uh yeah it's not leading anywhere
yeah
as usual if the knight could teleport to
f5 but yeah but this knight does has
been out of play for so long
all right rotate this doesn't quite work
well one thing i can do is maybe just
plug that a5 with the move knight to a5
oh just not allow your rook to get uh
to double up on the second rank
yeah that's that's a nice move that is a
very nice move the knight
from useless to hero making sure that
the rook doesn't penetrate either on a1
or a2 but now there's no more threat
there's no more rook takes d6 coming my
knight on e5 is stable
that's funny there's there's queen
definitely force that's right right d4
so maybe i have to try to
and i think he's going for it i think
yeah there's nothing else on that side
of the board right
uh i don't think so i also don't see
another option once you see the rook 6f2
mine run into problems
knight a5 yeah i think it has to be
knight a5 and he's down to his last
minute it's also knight a5 is a sort of
move which
kind of negates the possibility that you
lose because white seems relatively safe
there well if you allow the other rook
into the attack with rook a2 or rook a1
potentially then you're very much
risking losing the game so knight a5
and it also besides queen e4 it also
threatens queen b5 which is an important
pawn as well oh but he's actually
changed his mind he was reaching for the
knight but he did go with the move rook
6f2 will
ray who
is known
on his chess.com puzzle sprees as spicy
caterpillar one of the best puzzle rush
solvers in the world will he spot the
move queen f6 no it wasn't here it was
queen d4 rookie two rook uh six of two
queen f6 we need the rooks doubled oh we
need the rooms double first sorry my
baby is actually playing here maybe two
maybe that's that's a good question what
do you do after okay then rook c2 and
knight d6 i don't see the attack anymore
let's put that on the board here queen
two uh take six takes
queen takes d6 and now there's queen e5
on top so yeah this does looks pretty
bad and queen eight nine five i mean
black can just take on f2 that looks the
most reasonable option because then
you'll get your other rook in
potentially with check
uh white has to take with the rook and
he took it we see that exchange
happening right now all right rick a1
looks like a move
certainly
yeah now it's so concrete um
how does this proceed with a1 check for
sure right okay i don't know about that
for sure
king g2
i would really like to take 93 or knight
g4 but they both run into queen
well what if i take on d3 first
oh let's start with knight takes d3
you're saying
yeah what about rook f7 here i was
wondering that is the big question do i
have enough checks to create any sort of
danger for your king so let's say check
yeah king g2 check again with oh rook a2
doesn't work because the queen is
defending actually maybe it does work
huh maybe
queen e4
h3 now rook f3 runs into 91 91 let's put
let's put that out even this is not the
end of the variation right you give this
check you'd like to block with the rook
but knight e1 check picks at least some
material up do you have king to h3 i
think
is actually surprisingly no checks the
queen defense e6 the rook defense f5 the
knight can't
doesn't have access to these squares and
that would be the end of the game so
instead of rookie uh rook a2 black must
have something
uh must have something better so yeah
rookie won't check king g2
um
robson down to his last 45 seconds
probably you actually don't have many
viable moves because well there's too
many threats queen d4 and rook f8
potentially
and by the way i think he played the
best move in the position he played king
to g8
yeah wow oh i like this every time that
queen takes d4 it never pins the knight
you cannot take on d4 of course right
now because queen takes p7 is on top
so so you have to lose a tempo with
knight dave this threatens knight d3 now
that's why he defended both d4 at
well defended f7 and indirectly defended
d4 because it's no longer checked so
knight a5 allows an id3 and black is
yeah i don't know
what the valuation is but it suddenly
looks a lot safer black can even just
move the knight back to e5 next and and
even start thinking of this move of
course i was thinking about 65 but yeah
is kind of or maybe knight c6 right and
then 90 uh
95
95 just to defend
here on c6
uh doesn't allow the knight the knight
in because okay you can take b5 but then
you have to deal with that potentially
that past d-pawn maybe not immediately
but maybe queen to a7 and then d3 would
check and
uh it's very double-edged it's still a
three-result game here yeah for sure
white is white is risking as well
so what if we go maybe knight c6 after
knight takes d3 so knight to a5 knight
63 knight c6
and if take take on f2 black is probably
yeah yeah yeah this is a riskless
position i don't know how often i win it
but i think i win maybe queen g5 even oh
queenie oh queen g5 much stronger yeah
the same idea defend upon me five but
instead of defending the pawn passively
with queen e5 you have this queen e3
massive threat yeah it's either a drawer
or or black
yeah so let's see what happened a5 on
the board indeed we are expecting the
move knight takes d3 we don't really see
anything wrong with it and a pawn is a
pawn
it's a pretty good pawn too
yeah it's an automatic move i think
right and it's been played knight takes
d3
question is what does hans have planned
here is a queen to b5 a move or
queen b5 might be a move
uh i mean the thing is yeah black is no
longer worse for sure after knight of
two queen a6 but is he
better
is um hard to say
and it might be um kind of drawish
eventually
because white has queen ca queen g all
sorts of checks
and uh okay why is king is weak but so
is blacks
yeah queen b5 might be interesting he
actually played your first instinct of
the move uh knight takes e3 rook c2
bringing the rook into the game it
doesn't feel like it has any decisive
threats right now but it is very logical
to try to harass this king with the move
rook c8
so the idea being that if you take on b4
i'm just simply going to pick up all
your pieces off the roof to see but you
can do this actually
because you have queen e5 okay and then
queen a11
and um
then the question is which king is
weaker because king g2 rook a5
um
and of queen d6 there's rook a
rook a2 and queen f1 and
it feels like you get checkmate it feels
like black gets here
faster it's a bit difficult to say
because
f1 king g4
what yeah
yeah it feels like it should be
challenging h5 you go king g5 but then
right this is just checkmate here f6
queen takes you have to go to the edge
file and then there's actually queen f3
or well queen of truth made in one
that's three yeah whatever
i mean
if you go king to h4 now you go rogue
you're okay
yeah all right so rook c2 on the board
what is the time situation right now i
see six seconds for ray robson and he
played knight e5 he did not take at the
pawn on b4 all right this is i think a
more practical approach when you're
running out of time also because night
before allowed works here in queen b5
and black's pieces are extremely the 995
is just perfect not on b4 i love this
knight i love this knight and look at
that expression rook c8 check finally an
easy move here for ray robson king g7
played
immediately
and i think you have to take this pawn
right
i don't see
or queen b5 it's um he took it he took
out the floor right taking advantage of
the ring
you know you also have to be worried
that you just black sacks that rook like
queen g5 and just mates without correct
right yeah uh so
taking on d4 at least you pin the knight
you're kind of happy about that
so let's unpin the knight with queen f6
yeah and maybe uh maybe queen
f2 although even here i can now i can
just simply take and go knight d3 right
that's an extra yeah no that's actually
probably a winning end game right picks
up that one that's kind of ugly
so so yeah maybe king g2 after queen 06
really yeah at least like to give a
check you have to
you have to um
to re-pin your knight with black so king
g1
but you're
well yeah so king h3 queen g4 just loses
the rook yeah important to point that
out yeah this looks so risky for white
yeah i'm not a not a huge fan of the
move king g2
but maybe you have to do it right what
else can you do here you have you have
like queen c3 you have a bunch of moves
but none of them look super appealing
queen f6 was played yeah so we're gonna
find out i think this is the last yes
they made time control control ray
robson is
out
he's going to the restroom splash some
water into uh on his face
just take a breather wow what a time
scramble we had but it did seem like
both players
avoiding the riskier situations i can
imagine why as some of them just ended
up absolutely lost
for
both sides but here after the move queen
d4
queen f6
instinctively i like black it just feels
that the knight on a5 is so far away
from the action i understand that it's
blocking my own rook
but if i can never get it into the game
that's just going to be all she wrote
the on e5 is such a monster
yeah this is fully a two result game
um queen c3 queen e3 yeah why is
probably not losing or anything
yet but
it could could become losing at some
point well we've dedicated enough time
to this game they have reached time
control of course after this event uh
hans will probably take a long time to
consider his options make sure that he
defends appropriately uh christian you
have any updates any games that you want
to see that we haven't really been able
to look at well first of all i think
it's also time to release our prisoner
faviano thank you faviano for joining us
and uh hopefully we'll see you again in
the studio thank you guys thank you fabi
and